foreign
how did you teach yourself to write well
well that's good I mean a lot of
aspiring writers out there you know I
mean I wasn't aware of myself having
been anything like a writer and say high
school I mean I I later looked back and
was surprised to learn that I won the
English prize you know in the history
prize and I did have a tremendous
foundation in English grammar you know I
I went to a a private school in Montreal
in grade seven where we had to memorize
like the 120 sentence errors in English
grammar and literally we got whacked if
we didn't know them so you know that may
sound silly but but you know grammar is
the architecture of writing I mean if
you don't understand basic grammar you
can never be a writer and I have a
just an incredible
intuitive understanding of the grammar
of the English language because of that
experience when I was young and what
happened you know and I always kept
journals when I was on the road and I
certainly
was deeply impressed and I had mentors
like the poet Gary Snyder I never went
anywhere without one of Gary's volumes
of poems in my backpack Peter Matheson a
number of writers that I really admired
I was always drawn to the genre of
travel books because that's sort of what
I was doing who I was but what actually
happened with
with the case of the The Serpent of the
rainbow is as I said earlier in the
podcast
you know the zombie research was funded
by Dr Klein they set up a dummy
foundation called the international
psychiatric Research Foundation and
literally at the beginning if I needed
five thousand ten thousand dollars by
Wednesday I just had to call New York by
Monday night and I never knew who was
the benefactor but it turned out to be a
wonderful man David Merrick the Broadway
producer who at that time had just had a
huge success with on Broadway with 42nd
street and David had also done obviously
a number of feature films and he must
have been hearing from Dr Klein about my
Misadventures and he saw a film from the
very start in this and then again as I
mentioned earlier in a unbelievable 24
hours Dr Klein died during routine heart
surgery and Mr Merrick had a
debilitating stroke so I literally went
overnight from being flushed with
support to having none and I did apply
to all the standard research sources you
know various grants foundations but they
all take months and months to let you
know whether you're going to get the
money or not and I I had guided that
British journalist through the Darian
Gap his name was Sebastian snow and he
had written a really kind of dreadful
book about his journey called the
rucksacked man and he actually lifted
whole passages out of my Diaries into
his book which actually was a fair
exchange because it was the first time I
saw my writing in print albeit lifted
from my journals and he actually I was
able to give him something we're saying
because I spoke Spanish and was hanging
with the Indians all the time he knew
nothing about where he was he said if he
spoke to queen's English loud enough
they'd understand he he was just this
complete eccentric guy he went mad
actually on that in Costa Rica but
that's a whole other story but I thought
well my God if he he could write a book
I can write a book so that was an idea
he generously gave me the address of his
literary agent in London I walked off
the street and said I've got a couple of
ideas and this sort of Englishman looked
down his nose as they often do to
Canadians you know well there might be
something in that zombie thing and
before I I knew it you know I dictated
the story into a typewriter what
happened to me how to transcribe a type
bite the late EO Wilson secretary and I
had this big sort of 150 page thing and
I gave it in as a book proposal got a
contract for what then was an enormous
amount of money for me thirty five
thousand dollars spending on some fun in
Paris with a girlfriend and then use the
rest of it to finish the research and
then I had to actually write a book and
I wrote two chapters in Haiti I had
malarian hepatitis at the same time and
I was really sick and I wrote two
chapters that I thought was the best
thing since the Bible and I sent it to
the editor and he sort of sent it back
to me and said try again
and so then I then I left the University
and a very dear friend of mine sort of
plucked me out of Haiti and brought me
to her beautiful Farm in Virginia to
both get well but also to write the book
and I stayed there
working in a slave cabin for seven
months and I you know I had a great
story to tell I had lived this story I
just had to find the way to tell it so
what I did and no one gave me this idea
and I certainly had never taken a
creative writing course I mean most
creative writing courses are taught by
people who are teaching creative writing
courses because they can't write
creatively and otherwise they'd be not
doing that they'd be writing books but
that may be a little harsh but all of us
lots of times have to get academic jobs
don't get me wrong but what I did is I
just took all my favorite books
Hemingway for example for dialogue no
one's better Isaac Dennison for
landscape Lawrence Darrell in the
Alexandria Quartet how do you how do you
evoke the exoticism of places surreal is
Haiti well how about Alexandria the
1940s you know Carpentier for mystical
thing and this pile by my typewriter you
know kept changing and so on but it was
always there and I never obviously
copied or plagiarized but as I was
trying to tell my story and I was stuck
on how to
do it like what language to use I would
just pick up any book randomly and read
for a while and it was just weird almost
like by osmosis I would and I was often
writing at night I had lots of Coca and
I was kind of in this kind of creative
space and again you know
one thing that I think a lesson of all
that is in the end I wrote that book in
seven months and it was edited in the
single day and it came out and it sold
500 000 copies hold on hold on you say
edit it in a single day oh yeah almost
no editing whatsoever no okay all right
I got it got it got it what I mean by
that is there's lots of different ways
of writing you know some people like to
sort of spit out a first draft as they
say or you know or just puke it onto the
page well I've just never understood how
you could make something beautiful of
puke
so I to my detriment perhaps I'm a much
more laborious writer and I've never
done a second draft
of a book I do that in a way as I'm
going through you know as I write a
paragraph you know I'm paying attention
I think writing's analogous to sculpture
you know you're you got to pay attention
like Barbara tuckman the great historian
had a little note above her typewriter
will they turn the page you know and and
you have to create rhythms in every line
you have to end every paragraph with
something that's going to make the
reader one and it becomes unconscious
right but but at the same time you're
paying attention to the Cadence of every
word at least I am and that's when you
talk about lyricism and that was a skill
I had to learn in the early days you
know it was very funny my wife wouldn't
bother to edit or look at anything I
write anymore we've been married too
long but in the early days she was
wonderful at not editing per se she
never added any words or deleted
anything but she had a little stamp that
we called the puke meter and if I had
passage where I you know went beyond
lyricism the purple prose she just stamp
it you know like little faces from
throwing up and that was really kind of
wonderful because she was a great reader
and you learned
you can always go out on the lyrical
Edge if you will because you can always
pull it back but you can't
bring Spirit to dry prose you know and
it's interesting I mean like everything
else you get better and better the more
you do it now I write
bizarrely effortlessly I mean no one
writes effortlessly I mean we said
anyway says they write easily is either
a bad writer or a liar
also I've never mistook activity for
results because I've been self-employed
most of my life and I've never indulged
writer's block can you imagine if a
plumber came to your home looked at you
and suddenly
patted their brow and said just can't do
it today I've got plumber's block you'd
call them the police right no writing's
a craft you get up in the morning and
you do it but one of the things that
really was amazing to me a real turning
point in my life having been raised in
that kind of simple middle class
world where creativity happens to
someone else you know the Beatles are
creative Leonard Bernstein is creative
whatever when I finally understood that
creativity is not the motivation of
action it's a consequence of action if
you don't do you can't create so you
know that insight and acting on the
Insight changed my life I never sat
around to wait for permission to write
about any subject you know people will
say oh I can't write about World War one
because I'm a botanist no you you apply
the same research skills that you use to
write about the Haitian zombie to
understanding the essence of British
culture in Edwardian England you know
and in the same token you can't be a
photographer if you don't take pictures
you know the way you become a better
photographer is to take more and more
images and to study the work of the
Masters that's what I always would say
A2
a young person you know if you want to
write non-fiction
find the non-fiction that you think is
the best going and pay attention don't
just read it study it it's the same
thing with music listen to any of these
great characters from Jimmy Page to the
Beloved and late Jeff Beck just terrible
he passed away
they always talk about how they mind the
work of every other blues player before
them you know practice practice I mean
Jerry Garcia never had a guitar out of
his hands Northern Hendrix you know so
you just have to do it it's that classic
idea you know do what needs to be done
and only then ask whether it was
permissible or possible you know one of
the things that I found him about life
is that at every single stage of life
there's someone telling you you
shouldn't do something
and nobody wants you to change you know
in my case it was like you're from
Canada what's wrong with the university
why do you have to go to Harvard wait a
minute you're supposed to be a lawyer
what's this anthropology thing wait a
minute you didn't answer but what's this
botany thing we just came back from the
Amazon what's this Voodoo thing wait a
minute how can you go work on a logging
you can't your father just spent half
his money sending you to this fancy
School wait a minute you've been in the
logging Camp why should you be a park
ranger you know wait a minute it's
always like that and you just can't look
behind you I remember our mutual friend
Mark Plotkin once told me you know in
the early days you know the problem with
climbing up the flagpole is that there's
always somebody looking up your butt